[Música]
en medio del escándalo que vive el
príncipe andrew por la denuncia de abuso
sexual a una menor la reina isabel
segunda le retiró todos sus títulos
militares
el también duque de york será juzgado en
eeuu por su presunta implicación en el
caso por lo que el palacio de buckingham
indicó que tendrá que defenderse como
ciudadano privado
el presidente joe biden se mostró
decepcionado con la decisión del
tribunal supremo que bloqueó su mandato
a las grandes empresas para que
exigieran a sus empleados vacunarse a
presentar semanalmente pruebas negativas
de kobe 19 el mandatario señaló que son
medidas que salvan vidas
más de 77.000 profesores franceses
inundaron las calles de varias ciudades
del país para protestar contra lo que
aseguran son cambios constantes en los
lineamientos dentro del sistema
educativo a causa del hobbit 19 el
gobierno de manuel marrón ha
implementado en los cambios en un
intento por mantener abiertas las
escuelas
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez damos
inicio en reino unido- la casa real
británica informó que la reina isabel
segunda decidió retirarle todos los
títulos militares a su hijo el príncipe
andrew envuelto en un caso de presunto
abuso sexual contra virginia joe fue
cuando la mujer era menor de edad el
escueto comunicado del palacio de
buckingham indica que andrew enfrentará
su proceso como un ciudadano privado
el también duque de york será juzgado en
eeuu el proceso hace parte de la trama
del magnate jeffrey epstein y jeffrey
asegura que fue traficada por él en
repetidas ocasiones siendo menor de edad
[Música]
con la aprobación y el acuerdo de la
reina las afiliaciones militares y los
patrocinios reales del duque de york han
sido devueltos a la reina el duque de
york seguirá sin asumir ninguna función
pública y está defendiendo este caso
como ciudadano privado para analizar
este tema conectamos con hernán olano
experto en derecho nobiliario y realeza
bienvenido a france 24 porque la reina
isabel segunda toma esta decisión en
estos momentos de alguna manera influye
que este sea su año de jubileo de
platino
sí exactamente valentín a la reina
cumple 96 años y 70 en el trono quiere
evitar los escándalos y este es un
escándalo bastante grave con lo cual se
le retiran los títulos al príncipe
andrés seguirá siendo príncipe pero no
alteza real seguirá siendo conde de ay
venecia donde cada día pero no duque de
york y sus hijas beatriz y eugenia no
serán herederas al título de duquesa de
york a no ser que la reina les otorgue
el título y el tratamiento de antes a
reales de igual manera la antigua esposa
del príncipe andrés sarah ferguson a
quien por acuerdo de divorcio se les
seguía denominando la duquesa de york
también perderá este título bueno usted
ya lo estaba mencionando que otros
efectos prácticos tiene que se retiren
estos títulos ya que se refiere el
palacio de buckingham con quitar los
patronatos reales
pues precisamente valentín a los
patronatos reales corresponden a la
presidencia de varias fundaciones
tanto la reina como sus parientes
cercanos dentro de ellos el duque de
gloucester el duque de que en la
princesa alejandra y el príncipe miguel
de kent presiden algunas fundaciones
debido a que son muchísimas las que
hacen parte de la commonwealth y la
reina no puede junto con sus hijos
presidir las todas de esta manera la
reina guardará la preeminencia de
algunas de las instituciones otras
corresponderán al príncipe de gales a la
duquesa de cornualles al duque de
cambridge a la duquesa de cambridge a la
al conde de wessex su hijo menor y a la
princesa real ana quienes entonces
tendrán que asumir algunas funciones
adicionales ya que desde 2019 el
príncipe andrés en este caso podríamos
hablar de su alteza serenísima el
príncipe andrés ya no su alteza real
pues ha sido retirado de las funciones
en torno a la representatividad dentro
de la casa real inglesa bueno y como
queda la casa real con este escándalo se
ve afectada en reino unido-
claro que se ve afectada sin embargo el
orden de sucesión pues se modifica
igualmente porque después de la reina
sigue el príncipe de gales el duque de
cambridge el príncipe jorge de cambridge
carlota de cambridge
louis de cambridge después seguirían la
princesa beatriz y la princesa eugenia
hijas del duque de york el conde de
wessex lady luisa y el vizconde sever y
después la princesa real ana entonces
restringe prácticamente en 23 niveles el
orden sucesorio en la casa real
precisamente también por el retiro de
las funciones del duque de esos ex señor
olano usted muchas gracias por este
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en france24 vamos ahora a eeuu el
presidente joe biden aseguró que se
siente decepcionado por la medida del
tribunal supremo que bloqueó su mandato
a las empresas de más de 100 empleados
para que exigieran a sus trabajadores
que se vacunen o presenten pruebas
semanales negativas de kobe 19 para
seguir laborando sin embargo mantuvo el
mandato en instalaciones sanitarias
financiadas por el estado desde
washington cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal de france 24 nos dio más
detalles con seis votos en contra y tres
a favor la corte suprema de justicia de
estados unidos bloqueó temporalmente la
orden ejecutiva del presidente joe biden
que exigía a las empresas de más de 100
empleados vacunar a todo su personal
obligarlos a hacerse las pruebas
semanales y portar máscaras la decisión
de la corte de mayoría conservadora si
permitirá que como el obligado
inicialmente el mandato presidencial a
que los trabajadores de la salud tengan
que vacunarse para trabajar en los
centros de cuidado médico financiados
por el gobierno 84 millones de
estadounidenses se iban a ver afectados
por la medida esto es casi dos tercios
de la fuerza laboral en el país pero
ahora serán 17 millones de trabajadores
médicos que tendrán que vacunarse o
portar máscaras y hacerse las pruebas
cada semana la decisión de la corte
suprema viene en medio del pico de
contagio de coronavirus en eeuu donde se
reportan más de 780 mil casos diarios de
contagio por vikram continuamos en eeuu
porque en otro revés para el presidente
de byd en el senador demócrata joe
manchin se unió a la también senadora
demócrata kirsten cinema y no respaldará
la iniciativa de eliminar el filibustero
los demócratas requerirían mayoría
simple para poder acabar con el proceso
de obstruccionismo pero las esperanzas
de bailén que apoyó públicamente
acabarlo bloqueadas sin el respaldo de
los dos legisladores moderados tanto
vaivén como la mayoría de los demócratas
quieren aprobar dos proyectos de ley que
amplían y protegen el derecho al voto en
medio de la ola de restricciones
estatales impulsadas por los
republicanos
eliminar el umbral de 60 votos en una
línea de partido con la mayoría posible
para aprobar estos proyectos de ley que
apoyó no garantizará que evitemos que
demagogos ganen el cargo y son cosas más
de 77.000 docentes participaron en una
jornada de huelga o el caos generado por
el constante cambio en las reglas para
controlar la pandemia en las
instituciones educativas francesas el
paro estuvo acompañado de
manifestaciones en todo el territorio
también estuvieron presentes algunos
candidatos presidenciales los sindicatos
educativos fueron recibidos en la tarde
por el primer ministro ron castex el
ministro de sanidad boliviana y el
ministro de educación jean-michel
blanquea
y
estamos en huelga contra las políticas
que están intentando exprimir al
personal son las políticas gerenciales
las que son inaceptables en una
profesión humana porque un ser humano no
es un producto para ser vendido y
requiere personal suplente cuando los
profesores están enfermos este equipo de
maestros suplentes es cada vez más
pequeño cada vez tenemos menos en
alemania el ex coronel sirio anuar
razlan fue condenado a cadena perpetua
por el asesinato de 58 personas y por la
tortura de cuatro mil más en una prisión
de damasco se trata del segundo caso de
este proceso sin precedentes en el mundo
sobre abusos cometidos por el régimen de
bachar al asad
alemania aplicó el principio jurídico de
competencia universal que permite a un
estado juzgar a los autores de los
crímenes más graves sea cual sea su
nacionalidad o el lugar donde fueron
cometidos
este jueves se cumplen diez años del
choque del crucero costa concordia
contra una roca frente a la isla de
lirio en la toscana italiana un pequeño
grupo de sobrevivientes familiares de
las 32 víctimas fatales del suceso y
residentes locales que presenciaron la
tragedia de primera mano se congregaron
para rendir homenaje a los fallecidos
con una vigilia el costa concordia
transportaba a más de 4200 personas y su
capitán francesco que tino que fue uno
de los primeros en abandonar el navío
recibió en 2015 una condena de 16 años
de cárcel por homicidio involuntario
llegamos al final de este informativo
gracias por su sintonía volvemos en
breve aquí en france24
[Música]